Google's Dindin the New Deal is moving in along
with master politicians like James Farley and
Louie how the president surrounds himself
with bright young college professors such
as Raymond Morley Rexford guide Tugwell and
Adolph burly men who generate new ideas and
new policies they are the brain trust of the
Roosevelt Revolution bill after bill pours
into Congress from the White House whatever
Roosevelt wants he gets the house is burning
down says the Republican floor leader so give the
president anything he needs to put out the fire
through 100 historic days of a special session
every new deal measured passes without question
the country demands bold persistent
experimentation the president says
and the country gets Secretary of
Agriculture Henry Wallace launches
the AAA a program for managing and
controlling America's farm resources
the new Secretary of the Interior Harold Ickes
administers the PWA a program of pump the
secretary of labor Frances Perkins first woman
cabinet member expert in employment problems an
advocate of economic planning something like a
war psychology grips Washington as the shake-up
and government goes on night and day by headlong
trial and error everything from federal theater
projects to legalizing light wines and 3.2 beer
and an alphabetical avalanche of news fer a CCC
TV a 33 is NRA on the farmland paradox the New
Deal promises the more abundant life but in the
farm belt abundance is a burden now government
agents go about preaching the gospel of crop
control the economics of scarcity farmers are
paid not to plant the Triple A the Agriculture
Adjustment Act seeks to bolster farm income by
ordering crops plowed under and millions of acres
of wheat cotton corn are left on planted and
yet men are hungry but such measures are needed
so secretary Wallace is a shocking comment on our
civilization but farm prices do go up farm income
Rises men are going to work for the government
by the millions on new buildings roads schools
bridges anything to get thee forgotten man as
Roosevelt calls him off the bread lines and on
the job any job WPA it stands for Works Progress
Administration but critics say it really means
we poke along the Moondog link the shovel
leaning becomes the taut ministration whips